[Music]
[Music]
adele's new music video will have you
saying oh my god oh my god the 33 year
old grammy winner just dropped the new
music video for her latest single oh my
god off her latest album 30. and the
whole thing is giving off major
throwback rolling in the deep vibes
[Music]
in the edgy video adele sings while a
chaotic and gorgeous circus unfolds
around her i don't have to explain
myself
we're talking swing dancers gymnasts
sultry chair dancers there's even horse
people
[Music]
and the whole thing culminates with a
burning chair which fans speculate is a
nod to adele's 2010 music video which
also featured adele singing in a chair a
slow-motion dance performance and fire
[Music]
and get this sam brown who directed the
rolling in the deep music video also
directed the video for oh my god i'm
incredibly humbled by it on wednesday
the grammy winner posted a clip from the
video to instagram and dished on teaming
up with sam again quote to collaborate
together again a decade later was
nostalgic to say the least
i feel amazing about it adele also
revealed they filmed the video on the
same day that her track easy on me
dropped
[Music]
adele wrote quote there were a million
things going on all at once but the
attention to detail from the crew was
borderline hilarious thank you so much
for your patience and pulling it all
together it was a lot of fun it's an
amazing feat to have achieved and i am
of course very very grateful the singer
first teased the video last week posting
this clip in a gown standing in front of
a circular light she captioned the post
quote rested and reset feeling ready for
2022. there's so much coming i'm so
excited for you all to see it
too much
[Music]
well now we've seen it and we love it
and fans are listening carefully to the
lyrics which many speculate are all
about adele wanting to have fun after
her divorce from her ex-husband simon
connecky
[Music]
of course adele is now dating sports
agent rich paul i feel very lucky back
in november she praised her new man
during a chat with oprah winfrey calling
him hilarious and smart echoing which
she told vogue when she confirmed their
relationship in october at the time she
gushed over rich telling the mad quote
it feels like it's consistent and
considerate enough that i don't care who
knows he's great he's so [ __ ] funny
he's so smart adele my girl whether
you're singing about rich or not oh my
god we can't get enough
[Music]
[Music]
you